mhm so as an example I just had a press
meeting in San Francisco from uh noon to
1 mhm and okay cool but I forgot to put
in the travel time to get from here to
there and to get from there back so on
my calendar I just put 12 to one or no I
didn't even do it I was sent an
invitation right so you just clicked it
I just clicked it and accepted it okay
cool right no the person who's sending
me the the the calendar invite doesn't
know that I need travel time to get
there to there so something should have
prompted me to say okay when you click
accept now do you have travel time that
you need to enter around this thing
because I just clicked accept and moved
on to the next thing or or it could have
been intelligent enough to know by
location yeah where you are and then be
able to do that you know buffers buffers
should really be automatic right again
we know starting destination we know
ending destination right and so we
should be able to say to you this 1 hour
meeting is really going to cost you an
hour and a half right because we're
allocating 15 minutes to get there and
15 minutes to get back so in theory
you're not free at one you're free at
115 130 right right so buffers are
something that uh you know Microsoft
calendar doesn't handle no calendar
handles that so if there a way to prompt
for buffers cuz there abut there aren't
always buffers sometimes you know it's
fine phone calls and it's fine that it
back to back absolutely yeah so that
would be a help to
prompt people to put buffers in the
other big calendar thing rolling okay
the other big calendar issue I see is
the difference between my personal
calendar my family calendar my work
calendar right so you have all these
different calendars to manage and my
wife has things that she puts on her
calendar that I don't know about so
syncing calendars I don't know that
that's in your domain but you know it is
an issue with calendar
see our sorry our vision on this is that
you've got you know your calendar is
your time right and at the end your time
is your time whether you're at work
whether it's personal and so on and and
having two location where you're storing
two separate sets of data doesn't make
sense because they need to work in one
location so that's why for example we
did the multiple syncing where you can
sync your Gmail your outlook your
whatever so whatever you're using as
personal whatever you're using as work
you can have it all in one location and
start using that to better manage your
time but that's just one you know step
that we're do which really comes back to
the idea if you've got all of these um
data silos out there at the end of the
day I'm not a working professional or a
stay-at-home mom I'm I'm a person that
has a calendar with particular needs
right and that has to be managed from
9:00 to 5: but it also has to be managed
from 5 onwards right so it's a question
of scheduling time at the end of the day
right right right okay so here's another
one zne does a good job of handling your
email and processing telling you these
are the people that you uh send email to
most often or receive email from or did
you get did you get a copy of our agenda
before no is it doing great no uh or if
I did I didn't read it right um that's
sad but no I didn't um so zomie does a
good job of managing your email and
mostly in retrospect uh like for example
people don't know how they spend their
time right right uh so I've got a
calendar full stuff and if I tried to do
a retrospective of how did I spend my
time last month last year analytics on
calendar Nobody Does that that I know of
sure so the net net of everything we're
talking about is you've got these data
streams coming in right and so at the
end of the day it's the Calendar's
obligation to interpret the way you're
spending time go through the process of
analyzing the data provide you with
Insight right and so we see the net net
of this exactly is what you're saying
which is optimizing your life right two
problems that we know about people don't
have enough time and they have too much
information right we've got to
contextualize the information and
optimize their time right right so is
that on your agenda that's what I'm
saying we're actually working on it
right now there's there's an entire so
you know again we've broken this
manifestor out into um into chapters and
we there's an entire chapter that we
want to devote to to the analytical
component of all of this information
mashing together so sorry no as an
example you know we're talking about
things like four square data right um
being able to import my four square data
my feed into my Goog Google Calendar as
an example or tongle um provides me with
a completely historic view of where I've
been over the past x amount of days that
data will then feed a predictive engine
that says you know what it is time to
book a meeting a lunch meeting let me
look back at all the four square data
and see where I've checked in most often
um because there's a high likelihood
that that restaurant will work for me
right going forward yeah so the entire
recommendation component of this
optimization process of the calendar can
be fed by bringing in a bunch of
different data streams all of which in
their own way will bring insight into
what I'm doing so there's another
company called rescue time I don't know
if you know about that rescue time yeah
it um looks at how you spent your time
and helps you figure out how to rescue
some of it back right so that you're not
wasting time uh we're having an off-site
meeting for my group in Google U there's
about a hundred of us and one of the
exercises I'm going to ask them to do is
look at your calendar for the past four
weeks and put into buckets how you spent
your time and you're going to be shocked
at the way that you spent your time
right so analytics on how you spent the
time and maybe take a look at rescue
time and see what they do but I don't
even know I I just know about the
company and I know generally that they
analyze your time and try to to retrieve
some of it is that do you know if it's
self-reported in the sense that it is
okay yeah yeah so that's another
interesting area but and also what's
interesting is so we're talking about
the individual right how can they better
manage their time but then you can also
bring it to the Enterprise level and and
so seeing not necessarily like big
brother-ish you know he's not booking
enough meeting versus this guy but more
as a company here's how your team how
your employees are spending their time
here's how much they're traveling here's
where they're going here's how much you
could be saving by doing these little
tweaks and you know putting these
regulations or whatever here are the
restaurants where people are going and
maybe you can cut deals with these
restaurants and so on so there's ways
that we can leverage also for
Enterprises um analytics so that they
can optimize the time of their teammates
and also on on revenue and on cost as
well yeah um so we see that also as part
of our Enterprise play as we're getting
into companies it's spreading pretty
rapidly we're going to give analytics to
the individual users but at the same
point we can also give analytics to
corporations right yeah that's a good
idea uh I think analytics is critically
important another company uh six sense
analytics uh six sense analytics it got
acquired so it's not called that anymore
but basically what they did was they put
a uh agent on your desktop and it kept
track of every application that you used
and how much time you spent in each
application and uh then it did this
report uh to tell you this is where you
spent your time and which applications
and how much time and it also aggregated
it up and showed uh across all the
members of your group see it was kind of
big brother kind of like o I don't know
if I like this but it was actually
pretty interesting too much time on
Twitter not enough time on corporate
mail yeah and then you can compare
yourself to others in the group to see
you know how you're team and then
overall the company you know how team
was time was being spent that could be
beyond the bounds of what you're uh what
you're doing but it's just another way
to think about you know analyzing time
one of the other things that we've been
talking about is we you know we look at
the broad scope here is visualization
right the calendar grid is something
we've literally been looking at for
hundreds and hundreds of years as you
bring in these other data streams and
the calendar begins to become this
Dynamic application that's providing
insight into your life it's more than
likely that that grid is not going to be
the primary
interface let me give you an example um
we came out to San Francisco in the
valley and I've got meetings all over
the place I got meetings in Mountain
View poo Alto
Milas down in San Fran it would have
been wonderful to look at my week on a
map right another type of visualization
individuals location give me a sense
does this make sense or am I bouncing up
and down what does this look like right
um and so you know as we begin to think
about what does the model really look
like the question becomes does the
sandbox that holds this information
remain the
same I think we're also we've been you
know this grid has forced us to really
um I guess tag or index our calendar by
event title as opposed to other ways of
looking at it like location like
attendees right um give me a view where
I can look at literally look at the
thumbnails of the people that I'm
meeting over the next week right um you
know or plot those out on a map so that
I can see that I mean we've done it
we've been bouncing all over the place
whereas the calendar really should have
known you know what you're going to San
Francisco twice over the period of a day
let's move that to a separate day and
make sure that we're concentrating all
of the so defragging your calendar
exactly exactly yeah interesting so
defragging your calendar that's another
interesting topic to look at uh but a
lot of what I hear you talking about is
really what zne does for email tungle
does for calendar you know and zne has
been uh quite effective at mining uh
Trends and information and data about
your email that you use every day and
you're on top of it and you think you
know but there's a lot you don't know
there's a lot of analytics and trends
that you don't see so applying those
same things to a calendar could be
pretty interesting we're also looking at
all of these data feeds that right now
ex you know whether you look at the
location based services or the kind of
social applications that we're seeing
out there um none of them really have a
home in terms of context right so as an
example our plancast integration um
plancast is a great platform for
broadcasting intent I'm planning to be
at this event um but it's a standalone
application and there really is no home
for that data short of it being on
plancast own property for square as well
so you got this location based data that
is also uh very much tied to a
particular event but again doesn't exist
inside the calendar so you know we're
looking at this and saying you've got
all of this information that's
broadcasting out to your social graph
where I am where I'm going where I've
been who I've been with um you know
maybe we're a little bit close to the
glass but we believe that the calendar
would be the right hub for all of that
information from a contextual
perspective so instead of me having all
of these different applications that are
all pushing data Feeds out um um let's
have a place where we can aggregate all
this information and where it can have a
home right and as such we then have the
ability to start analyzing this data in
aggregate as well relative to my
calendar and where I'm going interesting
so here's another thing that may be
unique to me because I'm a b Coastal
kind of I live in Boston and I work in
Mountain View so I'm on either Coast um
I get invitations to
uh conferences and events and parties
and meetups and all kinds of stuff all
the time and I usually say no because I
don't know if I'm going to be there or
not which coast I'm going to be on or
which city I'm going to be in so right
it's too much work to unless it's really
really important to me I'm not going to
go to the effort of finding out okay am
I going to be in that City on this day
uh of the month and if I am okay I'll
say yes right so wouldn't it be cool if
um my calendar knows you know generally
where I'm going to be and it takes all
these events uh like events that maybe
I'm not even invited to just like
there's a seminar at Stanford uh
tomorrow night oh I'm going to be in
town tomorrow night oh I could I could
do that yeah um because I generally say
no because either I don't know about it
or I do know about it but I don't know
if I'm going to be in that place at that
time so I just say no so I'd like to
have a shadow calendar that says here's
my calendar that I'm committed to and
here's a shadow calendar that overlays
that says here's other options for you
you could choose this you can take it a
step further too like let's say we
communicate by email and you say yeah I
want to meet with Mark but the next time
we're in the same city but we don't know
when we're going to be in the same city
so you flag me saying tell me next time
me and Mark are on the same city and we
have some free time right so so tripet
tries to do that right yeah yeah but but
then it's contextualized in your
calendar and you can know when I'm free
and when I'm when you're free it's not
just that we're in the same city but we
actually have some free time boom we can
tell you by the way here's a free time
that you and Mark are free you're in the
same city the kind of suggestive
component that you're talking about I
mean you know we've we've talked about a
different use case but very much kind of
along the same lines my calendar as an
example knows that it's my wife's
birthday in two weeks right um provided
that I could tag my wife's profile and
now we're talking contacts we're not
talking calendar but I could add
preferences to that profile I know that
my wife likes at this particular store
she likes these particular Brands this
particular product the calendar could
know based on my schedule that I'm
passing as an example of Sephora I've
got a half an hour between meetings it's
her birthday coming up in two weeks now
would be a perfect time for you to stop
pull over buy that product that she
wants um so again knowing where I am
where I'm going where I need to be
what's upcoming in terms of my my
calendar um we can start to add in that
sort of suggestive component as well
right so this is pretty future thinking
kind of a lot of work and um I don't
know of anyone doing this kind of stuff
so is this you're putting together this
Future Vision of calendaring and what
you could do to um as a way to get
people interested in in calendar things
and buy what you have today or why are
you going so far out onto things that no
one has ever done